[Musique]
avez-vous déjà
eu un de ces cris
qui semble totalement réel
[Musique]
et une fois que vous vous êtes éloigné, réveillez-vous, réveillez-vous,
c'est un soulagement total
aujourd'hui, ça a plutôt bien commencé, je suppose qu'on se voit
ce soir,
je t'aime, je t'aime aussi bébé, allez,
nous
Je suis en retard, j'ai traîné avec Carrie Levi et j'ai
conspiré à propos de notre week
-end et tout est allé à la merde,
c'est des motifs cymatiques créés par
des fréquences
vibratoires  es-tu parti je t'ai
envoyé des SMS toute la nuit
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à faire ça ce n'est pas bien
il n'y a pas d'autre choix
si elle prend conscience que ce n'est qu'une question
de temps avant qu'ils ne deviennent un mot
tu as vraiment fait un gâchis cette fois
sait-elle où  elle est venue de salut mon
nom est aisha
si vous voyez cette vidéo cela signifie
bien cela signifie que
vous